hey it's evan i want to give you a quick
tip today for your gmail productivity on
how to use the tabs now
gmail came out with this new feature
where you have tabs at the top and if
you click here you can see they they
sorted automatically for you for primary
your main email social promotions
updates forums
and i disabled it at the beginning i
didn't find it helpful at all i didn't
like how they sorted everything so i
took everything off but i found a use
for it that i find really helpful in my
business so i activated one of them
forms and it could be anything that you
want and what i do here is i put in
the most important email so these are
emails from mostly my staff and my
family that you know if i open up my
inbox if i look at this i have 55 emails
to go through right now so you know i
mean i have time to go through all these
emails so the first thing i want to do
is i check my forums box and this is
where i'll get emails from
christina she's my video editor here uh
this is my mom
and uh what we're asking about here this
is ah pumpkins i found these pumpkins
uh on sale i wanted to know if we should
buy some for halloween so if i go back
to my my forums category whichever one
you want to use all the important emails
are here from the important people that
i need to get back to quickly and then
when i have more time i can check my
general primary inbox so the way to set
this up is if you have any email from
somebody that you want to move into your
important box so say there's there's
this email here this is from kareem if i
want i can move this here and what it
will do is just move that one
conversation here but then it'll say do
this for future messages from kareem's
email and i could do
yes if i wanted to and that would mean
every future email that i got from
kareem would go into this folder and so
it's a great way to be able to sort your
emails really quickly anytime you hit
your email you can quickly just go to
your forms or whatever category you use
and as far as i know you can't rename
these things yet but maybe that'll
change
this is not how gmail or google wants me
to use it it's not their intended
purpose but i found that their intended
purpose was useless for me
and i find this is a great way to be
able to actually sort my email quickly
the same options available on your
mobile device if you look at your email
there it'll say you know three new
emails in your forums and you can just
quickly go there so if i'm ever in a
rush i always check my forms emails
first my important ones
and then go to the rest of them to sort
so hopefully that's a quick tip that can
help you save some time using your gmail
if you guys like this video please give
it a thumbs up below if you have
questions about how to use gmail to
improve your business or any other kind
of productivity questions let me know in
the section below in the comments and
i'll do a video response thank you so
much and i'll see you soon